the Keanu Reeves Renaissance continues
largely via his John Wick movie
franchise about a beleaguered former
assassin but he has already appeared in
a whole host of great movies starring
beleaguered guys named John from Johnny
Utah to John Constantine to Don John but
easily one of the best and weirdest
Johns that Reeves has played is the
titular role in Johnny Mnemonic a much
derided movie in spite of its all-star
cast it almost single-handedly set back
the cyberpunk movement while earning
Reeves a Razzie nod for worst actor hit
me Reeves Johnny is trapped by his
circumstances he's traded in his
memories to be a data Courier his brain
is wired to receive uploads he wants to
do one big job in order to make money
and buy back the memories he's lost but
yesterday's technobabble is today's
modern age it's honestly a wonder that
Millennials haven't gravitated more
toward this movie while a fairly low
budget is no help the Flick's biggest
flaw is perhaps that it came out about
20 years too early for your average
moviegoers to relate to its cyberpunk
subject matter